.
>> Todd: PROFESSOR, JANICE DEAN.
>> Janice: NOT YET.
>> Todd: PRESIDENT BIDEN
VISITING PUERTO RICO TO VISIT
HURRICANE FIONA, HE MADE A
HEAD-SCRATCHING REMARK ABOUT
CONNECTION TO THE ISLAND.
WELCOME.
>> WE HAVE A LARGE PUERTO RICO
AN POPULATION IN DELAWARE, I WAS
RAISED WITH THE PURTO RICAN
POPULATION.
>> HERE IS REALITY OF THE
SITUATION, ONLY  .93% OF
DELAWARE WAS PUERTO RICO AN WHEN
HE WAS ELECTED TO THE SENATE.
>> Tomi: NOTHING SURPRISES ME
ANYMORE, I THINK HE WAS TRYING
TO MAKE A NICE STATEMENT, FIND
RELATABILITY, IT DOESN'T LAND
WELL WITH THE ACTUAL AUDIENCE.
EACH PASSING DAY WE HEAR FROM
THE PRESIDENT, HIM SAYING HINT R
HUNTER BIDEN IS THE SMARTEST MAN
HE KNOWS MAKES MORE SENSE TO ME.
>> Todd: YOU LAUGH AND YOU CRY,
YOU REALIZE HE IS LEADER OF THE
FREE WORLD AND ERIC ADAMS
DISMANTLING DAYS AFTER AOC, WHO
REPRESENTS THAT DISTRICT SPOKE
OUT.
SHE SAID, I THINK WE CAN GET TO
A PLACE WITH A BETTER SOLUTION
HERE.
TOMI, I THOUGHT SANCTUARY
SOCIALIST AOC WOULD WELCOME
EVERYONE WITH OPEN ARMS TO HER
DISTRICT.
WHAT DOES IT SAY MAYOR ADAMS
CAVED SO QUICKLY IN THE FACE OF
ONE TINY COMFLANT FROM AOC?
>> Tomi: DEMOCRATS LOVE THE IDEA
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND BEING
IN THE SHADOWS, WHEN THEY ARE
CONFRONTED AND HAVE TOIN SPLA
THE SHELTERS AND CITIES BEING
OVERRUN, THEY WANT TO MAKE THE
PROBLEM GO AWAY AND TOUT WHAT
THEY DO AS SOLVING HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
I AGREE, THERE IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS GOING ON AT THE BORDER,
WHERE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE
COMING IN.
MAYBE WE'RE GETTING TO THE POINT
AND I DON'T WANT TO BE OVERLY
OPTIMISTIC, MAYBE DEMOCRATS ARE
LOOKING AT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND SAY WE NEED A
SOLUTION BECAUSE WE'RE BEING
INUNDATED AND BORDER CITIES AND
STATES ARE BEING INUNDATED,
EVERYTHING SOUNDS GOOD UNTIL YOU
HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT IN REAL
LIFE.
AOC IS FINDING THAT OUT,
DEMOCRATIC MAYORS ARE FINDING
OUT AND I HOPE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WILL FIND IT OUT,
TOO.
>> Todd: MAYOR ADAMS BLAMING
FLOODING, I GUESS THINGS DON'T
DRY IN NEW YORK CITY.
CAROL
>> Carley: AND BUSSING MIGRANTS
NORTH USING FEDERAL MONEY AND
NOW SAYING IT IS HUMANITARIAN
MISSION AND THERE IS A REFORM
ANALYST WHO SAYS THE HYPOCRISY
ON DISPLAY BY DEMOCRATS AND
COASTAL ELITES TRANSPORTING
ILLEGAL ALIENS IS EITHER
PERFECTLY FINE OR INHUMANE,
DEPENDS WHO SENDS THEM AND WHERE
THEY GO.
>> Tomi: REPORTS ARE SUGGESTING
DEMOCRATIC MAYORS ARE SENDING
FAR MORE THAN ABBOTT AND
DESANTIS.
AS I SAID BEFORE, DEMOCRATS LOVE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS JUST NOT WHEN
THEY HAVE TO WELCOME IN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
I DON'T BLAME THE DEMOCRATIC
MAYORS FOR WANTING TO REALLOCATE
THESE PEOPLE TO OTHER PLACES,
FACT IS IT HAS TO START AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
DEMOCRATS ARE QUIET WHEN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS FLYING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO LIKE
MIDDLE TENNESSEE IN MIDNIGHT
FLIGHTS, I DIDN'T HEAR
COMPLAINING FROM THEM THEN, I
GUESS THE TUNE IS CHANGING NOW
THAT THEY HAVE TO BE CONFRON